Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Jetzt war gerade Warntag und das sogar in Schweden.
Das ist ein internationales Erfolgskonzept. Musik Musik Musik Musik.
Logbuch-Netzpolitik Nummer 532 vom 14. September 2025.
Diesmal habe ich mir das Jahr sogar gemerkt. Ja, und es macht dann in Schweden.
Also eigentlich sind die ja in der Lage, Location einzugrenzen.
Ich frage mich jetzt, eigentlich ist das dann,
natürlich, also bist du nicht eigentlich, also kannst du die jetzt nicht eigentlich verklagen?
Also das ist interessant, weil einer, okay, sie wollen dieses Konzept testen, ja, richtig.
Der Einzugsbereich, also du warst eigentlich nicht im Einzugsbereich, aber,
also interessant finde ich eher, dass Schweden von offensichtlich deutschen
Netzen diese Warnmeldungen entgegennimmt und den Leuten zustellt.
Gleichzeitig kannst du wahrscheinlich auch nicht sagen, wir filtern Warnmeldungen am Interconnect.
You have wrong assumptions. Du gehst gerade von der falschen Voraussetzung aus.
Du nimmst gerade an, dass ich irgendwie gewarnt wurde über das Mobilfunknetz.
Dem war nicht so, sondern es wird ja nicht nur darüber gewarnt,
sondern es wird ja auch über diese
Waren-Apps gewarnt, unter anderem Cut-Waren, was ja von dem deutschen,
Versicherungsunternehmen sozusagen bereitgestellt wird, aber die Teil dieses Warntages sind.
Ach so.
Und die Apps nutzen aber dann eben auch dieses Feature, dieses Privilege auf
den Telefonen, dass sie sich auch gegen Stummschaltungen und so weiter noch durchsetzen können.
Und das ist halt dann immer besonders lustig, wenn man dann so in so einer Konferenz
sitzt und dann weiß, wie viele andere Deutsche es auch noch gibt gerade in der Audience.
Die hat verantwortlich. Und
der Blick des Veranstalters war wirklich deadly. Das schaute mich so an.
Hast du dein Telefon nicht unter Kontrolle?
Ja, mein Telefon schon, aber ich habe irgendwie mein Government nicht unter Kontrolle.
Wir üben das mit den, naja, okay, interessant.
Ja, das ist so ein Ding. Naja, also es waren jetzt auch nicht so viele,
aber es gingen irgendwie so zwei Telefone los, die also offensichtlich auch
Katwan installiert hatten.
Okay.
Hat aber gedauert, das war dann nochmal so 30 Sekunden später.
Aber ich bin jetzt gewarnt.
Insofern können wir auch hier eine neue Themenliste einsteigen.
Ja, da fangen wir an wieder mit Feedback.
Das ist ja ein sehr beliebtes Segment, also wird es das auch dieses Mal geben.
Und natürlich haben wir wieder alles falsch gemacht.
Das kennen wir ja schon und zwar gab es besonders viel Feedback bezüglich unserer Falschaussagen.
Erstmal zum Thema Global Navigation Satellite Systems,
und ich habe gesagt, es gibt GPS, es gibt Galileo und es gibt GLONASS und ich
weiß nicht, irgendwie Chinesen haben vielleicht auch bald was.
Genau und die sind dann auch gleich mal in der Zeit zurückgereist und haben
also nachträglich nach meinem Kommentar ihre Satelliten auch noch gestartet.
Also es gibt selbstverständlich auch bei den Chinesen schon ein GNSS und das heißt Baidau. Bei Dow.
Und darauf wurde ich hingewiesen von EGAL und auch von Malte, der noch schreibt.
Und bei Dow hat mit 35 Satelliten auch aktuell mehr als GPS.
Indien und Japan haben auch noch eigene Satelliten, die unterstützen aber GPS
meist regional oder GNSS, also Navigation regional.
In Japan zum Beispiel für die tiefen Häuser, Schluchten, wo man meistens nicht
genug Satelliten in Sicht hat.
Daher auch der Name quasi Zenith Satellite System.
Die dazugehörigen Umlaufbahnen sind auch ziemlich abgefahren.
Wikipedia hat da schöne Animationen dazu in verschiedenen Koordinatensystemen.
Habe ich mir angeguckt, ist sehr lustig. Es sind tatsächlich solche,
die fliegen quasi so eine 8.
Das ist ja so ein typisches Konzept für Satelliten, um mehr oder weniger sich
an einem Ort aufzuhalten, wo man jetzt nicht geostationär ist.
Da fliegt man halt einfach so eine Acht. Das machen auch so Satelliten,
die an diesen Lagrange-Punkten hängen, also da, wo sich die Schwerkraft von
Sonne und Erde aufhebt und wo man so schön das Weltall beobachten kann,
ohne zu nah an der Erde dran zu sein, die ja viel zu warm und viel zu heiß und viel zu viel Funk hat.
Und ja, sowas gibt es offensichtlich eben für die lokale Navigation auch noch.
Aber die ist bei DAO, gibt es auch mittlerweile in Version 3 und ist seit 2020
operativ, also in dieser neuesten Version ist es operativ.
Und tatsächlich hat auch schon das, also chinesische Smartphones unterstützen
das natürlich schon länger, aber iPhone zum Beispiel hat das seit dem 13er,
also seit 2021 auch mit drin.
Das ist mir irgendwie entgangen.
Allerdings, und darum ging es ja bei uns primär, diese signierten Updates,
also signierte Informationen, die man später durch die Überprüfung eines Schlüssels,
der dann nachgereicht wird, überprüfen kann,
um dieses Spoofing einzudämmen, hat auch das chinesische System nicht.
Ja, dann gab es auch noch Hinweise zu GPS im Flugzeug.
Alex beim Elch schreibt, Ihr meintet in der Sendung, dass das Flugzeug zwei
GPS-Empfänger haben müsste und nur einer gestört wurde.
Ich denke, das ist nicht so. Moderne Verkehrsflugzeuge haben ein sogenanntes
Trägheitsnavigationssystem, INS, welches mit Laserkreiseln funktioniert.
GPS ist nur einer der Inputs in dieses System, welches auch ohne GPS für eine
gewisse Zeit seine wirkliche Position weiterhin gut berechnet,
aber dann halt mit der Zeit langsam davon wegdriftet.
Daher kann es gut sein, dass das GPS gestört war, aber ADS-B weiterhin die vom
INS berechnete Position ausgesandelt hat. Genau.
Dann müsste aber auch also die werden jetzt nicht dieses Lasersystem nicht dem
Cockpit zur Verfügung stellen, oder?
Das heißt, das Cockpit müsste ja dann auch weiter gewusst haben,
wo sie gerade sind oder nicht.
Ja, generell wussten die schon, komme ich gleich zu, also erstmal noch hier,
liebe Grüße aus dem Land des einzigen Daten, ehrliches Mitteleuropas,
da können wir jetzt raten, wie es das sein könnte.
Österreich.
Ne?
Genau, also es gibt generell in den Kommentaren, falls ihr euch da noch vertiefen
wollt, eine Tonne von sehr ausführlichen Kommentaren, die ich jetzt hier nicht
alle vorlesen werde, zum Thema Technik im Flugzeug und so weiter.
Vielen Dank für die ganze geteilte Expertise.
Also diese Wahrnehmung, GPS sei jetzt sozusagen das Einzige,
womit sich so ein Flugzeug positionieren kann heutzutage, das ist eigentlich
das, was jetzt hier die Kernaussage ist, dem ist halt nicht so.
Es gibt eben unter anderem eben auch diese Trägheitsnavigationssysteme,
die alle in irgendeiner Form dazu beitragen, um in irgendeiner Form eine Positionsmeldung zu machen.
Für den Anflug jetzt an einen Flughafen war das aber jetzt nicht die Option
und da es eben offensichtlich eine Störung gab.
Gab es dann entsprechende Kommunikation mit dem Flughafen.
So, also es ging ja hier um den Fall von von der Leyen, die eben diesen Anflug
hatte mit einem gecharterten Flugzeug auf die bulgarische Stadt Plovdiv.
Und Christian merkt noch an den Kommentaren bei MentorNow, kann man sich das
auch nochmal erklären lassen.
Link auf ein YouTube-Video, das habe ich mir angeschaut.
Ich finde es übrigens ziemlich enttäuschend, dass Tagesschau.de bis heute nicht
den Artikel korrigiert hat.
Mir ist aber auch unverständlich, wieso man Quellen wie Financial Times oder
Bild überhaupt verwendet.
Das ist für mich eine journalistische Bankrotterklärung.
Genau, also ich habe mir das Video nochmal angeschaut und Takeaway ist jetzt,
was diesen Flug konkret betrifft, weil es eben da eine etwas verstörte Berichterstattung gab.
Also erstmal, es ist offensichtlich aus entsprechenden Quellen,
dass es tatsächlich in Plovdiv zu diesem Zeitpunkt in irgendeiner Form GPS-Interference gab.
Ich hatte ja glaube ich gesagt, Plovdiv ist relativ weit weg vom Kriegsgeschehen,
ist es auch, trotz alledem gab es wohl tatsächlich eine nachweisbare Störung.
Die haben ja diese Piloten dann auch bemerkt und haben das dann dem Flughafen
gemeldet und daraufhin sich eben auf eine Alternative beim Anflug geeinigt.
So machen die Piloten das.
Und das ist jetzt insofern eben auch nichts Besonderes.
Es gab dann noch diese Meldung, dass angeblich das Flugzeug dann jetzt eine
Stunde noch über Plovdiv hat kreisen müssen.
Dem war nicht so. Es gab zwar eine Verspätung, aber die betrug nur neun Minuten.
Das mit der Stunde mag in irgendeiner Form falsch interpretiert.
War stundenlang noch eine gefühlte Stunde?
Die Vermutung ist, dass bestimmte Journalisten hier sich Timetables angeschaut
haben und dabei die Zeitzonenwechsel nicht berücksichtigt haben.
Also es gab diese Stunde schlicht einfach nicht, sondern eben nur neun Minuten.
Und das war einfach das Resultat aus der dann gewählten Anflugsmethode, die dann bedeutet,
dass das Flugzeug nochmal so eine Schleife geflogen hat über ein stationäres
Funksystem, was an dem Flughafen dran ist,
womit man sich dann sozusagen nochmal konkret synchronisieren kann.
Und das ist dann nicht abhängig von irgendwelchen Satellitensystemen.
Das ist irgendwie so ein im Kreis aufgebautes Funksystem.
Kenne ich nicht. Egal, wird in diesem Video alles ausführlich erläutert.
Ist jetzt eigentlich auch für diesen Fall egal.
Aber dadurch, dass sie eben sich quasi wegen der GPS-Störung auf diesen anderen
Anflug geeinigt haben, der jetzt auch nichts Außergewöhnliches war,
sondern das ist eben das, was die Piloten in ihrem Kartenmaterial auch haben, für jeden Flughafen.
Da gibt es dann eben so verschiedene Anflugsysteme, wo fliege ich jetzt lang?
Und wenn man sich dann mit dem Tower abgestimmt hat, welche man die nimmt,
dann nimmt man die halt einfach und das ist dann immer auch genau die Route,
die sie genommen haben und dann sind sie gelandet und dann waren sie neun Minuten
später da als ursprünglich geplant und alles war super und von allein war auch
nie in Gefahr und hat auch schön da irgendwie.
Ihre Munitionsfabrik besucht oder was das war.
Alles gut. Ja, so viel dazu.
Genau, dann gab es noch eine Korrektur in Bezug auf unsere Diskussion um PayPal.
Da hatte ich ja gesagt, dass PayPal jetzt auch Echtzeitüberweisungen hat.
Das war dann so eine Information, die habe ich dann halt in Echtzeit auch nachgeschlagen
im Internet und dann habe ich irgendeine Zeile vielleicht falsch gelesen.
Auf jeden Fall werde ich korrigiert von Stefan, der schreibt,
bei Paypal gibt es übrigens mittlerweile die Möglichkeit, das Guthaben kostenfrei
per Echtzeitüberweisung auf das eigene Bankkonto zu transferieren.
Ich hatte glaube ich gesagt, das kostet irgendwie Geld, wenn man das dann per
Echtzeit machen soll, ist nicht so.
Also könnt ihr ganz beruhigt auch von Paypal schnell Geld abholen.
Von Geld.
Genau. Wir haben so wenig. Ja, und das war es dann auch schon mit dem Feedback.
Sehr schön. Dann können wir uns ja jetzt überlegen, wie wir das Web retten.
Und das ist ganz, also ich meine, das ist ja nun wirklich eine ein sich offensichtlich,
sehr zeitnah aufdrängendes Problem,
wir haben in mehreren Sendungen hier auch darüber gesprochen,
dass mit den Machine Learning Systemen die Notwendigkeit zu einer Primärquelle
zu gehen immer geringer wird.
Ich denke, das herausragende, das Killer Feature von HTML ist der Link.
Ohne Link hätte sich das Web nicht durchgesetzt.
Das HT in HTTP.
Hypertext.
Genau, das ist sozusagen das Ding und das hat sich ja bewährt, kann man sagen.
Dass ich eine Stelle im Text oder in dem Bild, in dem Dokument,
was ich da darstelle, markieren kann und sage, wenn man hier hinklickt oder
tippt, dann geht es an eine andere Stelle.
Und dadurch haben sich ja sehr viele besondere Dinge im Internet entwickelt, Werbung,
aber auch überhaupt das, was man Vernetzung nennt, dass ich jetzt Inhalte innerhalb
einer Seite, aber natürlich auch über das gesamte Netz verlinken und referenzieren kann.
Und dadurch hat sich Information zu Beginn sehr über das Internet verteilt und
die Bemühungen der Konzerne waren immer in irgendeiner Form,
hier eine Konzentration herbeizuführen.
Sei es Google, die eben viele Jahre oder Jahrzehnte davon gelebt haben,
dass das Internet zu groß ist und Menschen etwas darin suchen und ihnen gesagt
werden muss, wo es steht und deren Geschäftsmodell sich jetzt auch langsam dahin entwickelt,
nicht mehr nur Leuten anzubieten, wo sie vielleicht eine Antwort finden.
Sondern diese Antwort zu geben.
Und die Konsequenz daraus ist natürlich, dass das Risiko besteht,
dass es immer weniger Anreiz gibt, so etwas zu machen wie eine Webseite zu betreiben
oder genuin neues Wissen diesem Internet hinzuzufügen,
wenn immer weniger Menschen noch das Internet besuchen oder im Web überhaupt unterwegs sind.
Und wir haben es ja wirklich sehr häufig hier besprochen, dass du von Chat-GPT
Antworten bekommst und von Google auch in zunehmendem Maße und ich denke,
dass diese Tendenz nun besteht, ist völlig klar.
Also muss man unter Umständen, auch darüber haben wir sehr häufig gesprochen,
überlegen, wie finanzieren wir denn jetzt hier das noch?
Und dann gibt es ja zum Beispiel diese ganzen Medienunternehmen wie die großen
Verlagshäuser, die ja, was weiß ich, New York Times, Wall Street Journal,
sicherlich auch deutsche Verlagshäuser, auf jeden Fall Springer,
die halt dann, sicherlich auch die anderen, die irgendwie Deals mit den AI-Unternehmen
machen und sagen, alles klar, hier, Chat-GPT darf jetzt unsere Seiten scrollen
und wir kriegen dafür so und so viel Geld.
Und dann haben die irgendwelche Nutzungsvereinbarungen.
Das sind aber natürlich auch große Häuser, die mit ihren.
Gut, bei Springer jetzt natürlich schwierig, aber die in irgendeiner Weise genuin
neue Inhalte recherchieren, fabrizieren und so, die für so ein Modell dann irgendwie interessant sind.
Jetzt gibt es natürlich aber auch die Diversität des Netzes,
die sich eben auch in kleinen Blogs, Podcasts, Webseiten immer noch ein bisschen widerspiegelt.
Wir haben da ja diese Zentralisierungstendenzen, die sicherlich auch sehr zu
beklagen sind, dass nämlich immer mehr Diskussionen an zentralen Stellen stattfinden,
die sich Netzwerk nennen,
wie Facebook oder X oder was auch immer, die nicht mehr wirklich Vernetzung
sind, sondern zentrale Plattformen.
Also diesen Effekt haben wir auch. Was ist also mit dem freien kleinen Netz,
wo Menschen kleine Webseiten unterhalten, so wie wir das tun?
Da haben bisher die AI-Unternehmen gesagt, ja, ja, alles klar,
das ist fair game, das nehmen wir einfach.
Das haben die ja ins Internet geladen.
Da gab es dann auch schon die Auseinandersetzung, dass beispielsweise Perplexity
die Robots TXT ignoriert.
Auch wenn dann gesagt wurde, wenn jetzt Leute in ihre Robots TXT geschrieben
haben, ich möchte diesen Perplexity-Bot hier nicht haben, hat Perplexity gesagt,
ja, da gibt es keinen rechtlichen Anspruch drauf, haben wir nicht gesehen,
zack, bumm. crawlen wir weiter.
Was ist die Robots.txt? Die Robots.txt ist eine Datei, Textdatei mit einem sehr einfachen Format,
wo du beispielsweise reinschreiben könntest,
dass du möchtest, dass der Googlebot bestimmte Teile deiner Seite nicht indiziert
oder vielleicht auch die gesamte Seite nicht indiziert oder nur sagst du,
ich möchte bitte nur, dass du, oder du kannst auch,
Hilfen bieten und sagen, pass auf, das und das hier ist, das ist spannend,
die Startseite, da würde ich dir empfehlen, dass du die täglich crawlst und
alles, was hier irgendwie das Jahr 2024 im Domain.
In der URL hat, das brauchst du jetzt nicht mehr zu scrollen,
weil da wird sich auch nichts mehr ändern, da empfehle ich dir vielleicht mal
monatlich vorbeizuschauen und so kannst du oder was ist das,
So kannst du eben den Crawlern verbieten, deine Webseite zu besuchen und ihnen
weiterhin auch gute Empfehlungen geben, wie sie effizient mit deiner Webseite
umgehen können oder mit deiner Webseitenstruktur.
Und wenn du das tust, wenn du ihnen gute Tipps gibst, dann belohnen sie dich
dafür und finden das schön und richtig.
Verbieten ist schwierig, weil Robots TXT ist jetzt kein irgendwie rechtsgültiges
Ding und es ist eigentlich auch nicht wirklich als Verbot gedacht, sondern das Problem,
was eigentlich von Anfang an als erstes damit gelöst werden sollte, waren so Sachen wie,
dass man eine URL hat, wo dann quasi eine Suche eingegeben wird und man verhindern möchte,
dass der Webcrawler, den man ja gerne sozusagen sagen wollte, was hier zu finden ist,
dass die nicht in irgendwelche Skripte reinlaufen und sich da ewig drin verlaufen,
weil sie quasi einen unendlichen Suchraum auf einmal aufmachen,
indem sie mehr oder weniger immer wieder sich durch dieselben Daten durchwühlen und nicht merken,
dass es hier in dem Sinne eigentlich gar nichts zu holen gibt und andererseits
dieser Webseite extrem Trouble machen, weil die sozusagen gerade alle nur mathematisch
möglichen Links klickt und die ganze Zeit die Datenbank nach irgendwas durchsucht
wird, obwohl eigentlich nach gar nichts gesucht wird.
Das ist so ein bisschen der Ursprung gewesen und es ist,
sagen wir mal, eine diskussionswürdige Interpretation, dass das Ganze eben jetzt
wirklich so ein, hier sollst du nicht rein, weil ich muss jetzt hier meinen
Content schützen, Mechanismus ist.
Nee, nee, genau. Aber du kannst, es ermöglicht dir auch zu sagen,
was weiß ich, User Agent Googlebot Disallow Sternchen.
Und dann sagst du halt, hier gibt es für dich nichts zu sehen.
Genau, also Robots.txt unterstützt eine Reihe mehr, wo du sagen kannst,
hier mal bitte nicht, hier mal bitte lang.
Du kannst aber eben auch sagen, du möchtest das gar nicht, du möchtest den gar nicht hier haben.
Und dann hast du keine rechtliche Handhabe.
Aber ganz grundsätzlich ist das eben von vielen Crawlern eine Zeit lang durchaus
auch gewürdigter Standard.
Ja, dann gibt es noch dem, daran anschließend kannst du so eine Sitemap auch
in deiner Robots.txt beispielsweise verlinken, wo du sagen würdest hier,
um es dir noch einfacher zu machen, habe ich hier eine XML-Datei,
wo ich dir schon mal die Struktur dieser Seite nahelege oder so.
Na, das gibt es dann alles.
Also, regelt die Interaktion mit einem potenziellen Crawler,
der das unter Umständen sogar würdigt, was du ihm sagst.
Ich glaube, du konntest damit.
Weiß ich nicht, Internet Archive oder so, konntest du damit auch ausladen oder spezifisch einladen?
Sowas halt. Also das gibt es und ist aber erst mal ganz gut.
Ich gucke mir gerade mal meine Robots TXT erinnere mich vor Jahren das letzte
Mal mit auseinandergesetzt.
Ich sage zum Beispiel, alles wo PHP dran steht, brauchst du gar nicht zu machen.
Oder Bilder bitte nicht.
Google Image Spot darf, soll keine Bilder von meiner Webseite nehmen. so Kram.
Genau, und hier Internet Archive, Archiver, habe ich auch gesagt,
soll er nicht machen. Die haben aber immer gesagt, das interessiert sie jetzt
nicht mehr, das honorn sie nicht mehr.
Naja, okay, also, das gibt es auf jeden Fall.
So, jetzt gehen und Perplexity und Anthropic beispielsweise sind dafür bekannt,
dass sie das ignorieren und sagen, interessiert uns nicht.
Das Problem, was jetzt das RSL-Kollektiv regeln möchte, ist nicht nur die Frage,
was machen wir mit diesen ganzen AI-Crawlern, die ja nun inzwischen eben auch
starke Last auf bestimmten Webseiten mitunter produzieren, sondern dass sie
auch gleichzeitig sagen,
wir werden übrigens hier jetzt auch eine Sprache und eine API für Lizenzbedingungen definieren.
Also die sagen, du hast jetzt eine Webseite und sie bauen quasi auf der Idee
von Robots.txt auf, erweitern die, ergänzen die,
und da würdest du dann zum Beispiel in die Robots.txt reinschreiben,
hier gibt es Inhalte,
was weiß ich, unter diesem URL oder alles, was dahinter liegt, oder diese fünf.
Möchten wir nicht, dass du die indizierst, aber eben der interessanter Teil,
der jetzt das Web dann retten kann oder die Idee, das Web zu retten,
ist, dass du definierst,
da bezahlst du, wenn du das hier crawlst, bezahlst du für einmal crawlen oder
das hier kannst du kostenlos crawlen oder hier hätte ich gerne,
dass du mich pro Bezugnahme in einer Antwort bezahlst.
Also sie definieren Lizensierungsmodelle,
die du in einer Robots.txt dann direkt bekannt geben kannst und dann haben sie eine API definiert,
wo sie quasi auch die Inanspruchnahme und potenziell eben auch Bezahlung einer
Lizenz direkt abbilden würden.
Um das jetzt vereinfacht darzustellen, der Crawler kommt auf meine Webseite
oder auf Logbuch-Netzpolitik Und
dann steht da, du darfst die Shownotes indizieren, aber die Transkripte,
wenn du wirklich auf die Transkripte Bezug nimmst in einer deiner Antworten,
dann möchten wir gerne dafür bezahlt werden.
Dann möchten wir ein Bitcoin oder was auch immer.
Ein Millionen pro Episode. Pro Zugriff.
Oder genau, wenn du hier einmal vorbeikommst, dann möchten wir dafür bezahlt
werden, für ein Crawl-Ereignis allein schon. Und.
Zumindest kann man das jetzt machen oder kannst das da hinschreiben.
Und dann in dieser API haben sie dann das Open License Protocol definiert,
wo der Client sich, also der Crawler in dem Moment, sich quasi für ein Asset,
das du da bereitstellst,
die Lizenz direkt kaufen kann.
Von eben in dem Fall einer zentralen Stelle, die, so würde ich das Protokoll
jetzt interpretieren, eben von dem RSL-Collective im Zweifelsfall betrieben wird.
Das heißt, der Chat-GPT kam jetzt da vorbei, guckt in meine Robots-TXT,
sagt, ah, alles klar, hier gibt es Inhalte, da muss ich jetzt bezahlen,
wenn ich die einmal crawlen will.
Dann hole ich mir über diese API von dem RSL-Collective mal eben die Lizenz.
Und dann mache ich das, was hier vereinbart wurde.
Und dafür unterstützen sie sogar eine, also sie unterstützen dann quasi auch
die verschlüsselte Bereitstellung dieser Inhalte.
Das heißt, du würdest, du stellst jetzt quasi, was weiß ich,
diese Inhalte, die kriegt dieser Bot von dir nur verschlüsselt.
Und damit er sie interpretieren kann, würde er sich dann eben beim RSL-Kollektiv
den symmetrischen Key dafür kaufen.
Also du könntest quasi über diese Verschlüsselung auch tatsächlich das versuchen,
etwas besser zu entforcen.
Oder du sagst zum Beispiel, alles klar, hier wird per Crawl bezahlt und dann
stellst du deine Inhalte jeden Tag unter einem anderen Schlüssel bereit.
Und dann könnte der nur crawlen, wenn er sich eben auch wieder diese einen Crawl-Lizenz gekauft hat.
Ja, gleichzeitig hat das Ganze natürlich so eine Art Security-Fuß,
Pferdefuß, dass du ja offensichtlich dem restlichen Internet deine Inhalte unter
anderen Bedingungen ermöglicht, also bereitstellen möchtest und dann der Crawler,
wenn er jetzt einfach deine Webseite crawlen würde,
das sicherlich auch hinbekäme, aber dann verletzt er eben ja auch die von dir
bekanntgegebene Lizenz.
Also die Idee, denke ich, was sie hier haben und da haben jetzt Unternehmen wie Reddit,
Medium, Quora, Yahoo und so haben auch gesagt, wir werden das unterstützen,
wir finden dieses Really Simple Licensing, dafür steht RSL,
gut und wir werden das auf unseren Seiten implementieren und potenziell auch, sofern wir crawlen,
auch implementieren oder unterstützen.
Um so etwas in Richtung eines Standards zu schieben.
Das ist ja immer so bei den Internetstandards.
Die werden zum Standard dadurch, dass Leute sie respektieren. Es gibt die...
Eigentlich nichts, was wirklich ein verabschiedeter Standard ist im Sinne von,
da kommt jetzt der TÜV und checkt, ob du den jetzt wirklich unterstützt oder
du musst den unterstützen oder sowas,
sondern diese ganzen Standards, darauf wird sich geeinigt, die werden verabschiedet
von Arbeitsgruppen und werden angeboten, so würde man das im weitesten Sinne nennen.
Und hier gehen die jetzt eben hin und bieten einen, nach meiner Kenntnis,
auch den ersten zumindest halbwegs durchdachten und von einer größeren Anzahl
Stakeholdern jetzt auch in Betracht gezogenen Standard an,
wie so etwas eben funktionieren könnte.
Also das Ganze baut auf einem bestehenden Standardprotokoll auf,
auf dem Open Authentication aus.
Das kennt ihr indirekt wahrscheinlich, weil das ist so der Standard,
den man benutzt, wenn man sich mit einem anderen Provider irgendwo einloggt.
So Login with Apple, Login with Facebook, Login mit Google und so weiter.
Da kommt sowas zum Einsatz und das Protokoll selber hat schon immer so eine
Erweiterung des Protokolls vorgesehen.
In diesem Fall ist es ein sogenannter Grant-Type, der hier genutzt wird,
um sozusagen dieses Open-License-Protokoll on top of OAuth zu implementieren.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, wenn ich mir das so anschaue,
ob jetzt sozusagen hier auch ein automatischer Kaufvorgang selbst mit drin ist
oder ob es nicht nur der Nachweis quasi, dass man so etwas erworben hat,
hier automatisiert wird.
Ja, dann hast du es nicht weitergelesen. Also erstmal ja, der Identitätsprovider
in diesem Fall ist dann...
RSL oder andere, da könnten ja auch mehrere sein. Und dann ist der nächste,
acquire an RSL license for a digital asset.
Also du schreibst dahin dieses, ich hätte gerne einen Grant-Type hier nach dieser
Lizenz, die hier angegeben ist und dann holst du dir das von der API.
Also das würde ich schon so verstehen und da die Antwort ja dann eben ein Access-Token
ist, mit dem du dann eben auch zugreifen kannst, würde ich schon sagen,
dass der Lizenzkauf hier abgebildet ist.
Diese API ist aber so Version 1.0 Draft und da wird sich sicherlich noch einiges
ändern, aber sie haben überhaupt mal eine Idee,
dass du einfach lizenzieren kannst, weil dir jemand anderes quasi dein Identity
Provider ist und du hier quasi potenziell eben ein,
also ich weiß nicht, ob sie auch das Inkasso machen, aber quasi die Akquisition
einer Lizenz, Die ist auf jeden Fall jetzt erstmal mit einer durch Dritte verifizierten
Identität erstmal möglich.
Ich bin mir sicher, das werden wir dann in den Kommentaren nochmal genauer erklärt
bekommen, aber hier steht ja im Prinzip nur, serves as proof that the client
has acquired and licensed.
Also wie auch immer, das ist sozusagen jetzt hier das Framework,
mit dem so ein Workflow ermöglicht werden soll.
Ich glaube nicht, dass hier der Kauf selber dann automatisiert abwickelt wird.
Aber sonst macht es ja keinen Sinn. Also wie das hier gedacht ist,
jemand meldet sich an bei einem, was weiß ich, RSL-Provider.
Dieser RSL-Provider meldet,
bürgt über OAuth als Identity Provider, gegenüber dem, dessen Seite besucht
hat, sagt dann, hier, ich bin der Chat-GPT,
und ich würde gerne, ich habe mir, ich habe auf jeden Fall diese Lizenz jetzt
gerade acquired bei meinem Identity Provider.
Ich möchte gerne einen X kaufen.
Genau. Und du würdest dann eben diesem, das ist ja die Idee von OAuth,
Du traust dem Identity Provider und auch dem, was er dir mitteilt und sagt, hier,
der hat gerade diese Akquisition bei mir durchgeführt.
Wie am Ende das Geld gekleert wird, steht hier nicht notwendigerweise drin.
Das ist auch nicht Teil dieser Spezifikation.
Aber grundsätzlich würdest du, also die Idee von OAuth ist, dass jemand anders für Identity bürgt.
Das ist ja das, was halt passiert, wenn du log in with Google,
log in with Facebook, log in with Apple oder so,
dass du der Instanz traust, dass sie für
diese Identität oder die erfolgte Authentifizierung dieser Instanz bürgt.
Und das macht schon halbwegs Sinn, da OAuth zu nehmen, weil das eben auch wieder
ein offenes Protokoll ist, das heißt, du würdest diesen gleichen Standard eben
auch mit unterschiedlichen anderen.
Sprechen können.
Also der ist nicht,
Also der technische Standard ist offen und kann eben auch von anderen adoptiert werden.
Und dann siehst du hier zum Beispiel eben in so einer Robots.txt würdest du
dann eben schreiben, ah ja, pass auf,
hier ist die Lizenz, unter der bestimmte Inhalte sind und die liegt in Form
einer XML-Datei vor und dann kann irgendjemand hier sich das anschauen oder nicht.
Zumindest haben sie sich mal technisch überlegt, wie man hier Lizenzrechte strukturiert
im Rahmen größtenteils bereits existierender Standards wiedergeben und auch
deren Inanspruchnahme abbilden könnte.
Finde ich erst mal interessant.
Ja, mal gucken.
Hier zum Beispiel dann, dass du sagst, hier bei Images, in dem Ordner Images,
da ist der Payment-Type-Attribution, also du musst nur Attribution machen und
der Standard ist dann hier, das ist nämlich jetzt Creative Commons License CC
BY 4.0, dann hast du die angegeben.
Oder du sagst, hier ist der Payment-Type Royalty. Also hier wird,
Geld verlangt und dann sagst du, und zwar ist das die RSL Collective License
vom Typ Royalty und verlinkst dann diese,
und jetzt würdest du in dem Fall Royalty, würdest du sagen, die Lizenz ist, ich möchte,
bezahlt werden, wann immer du eine Antwort, deine AI, ein Resultat liefert und
diesen Content dabei genutzt hat.
Interessant.
Also man kann sich dann sozusagen auch für jede Auskunft noch bezahlen lassen.
Da werden die bestimmt alle mitspielen.
Hm, na genau, also ...
Und guck mal, es kommt ja so ein bisschen drauf an. Also ich finde,
da hat ja schon mal schon jemand drüber nachgedacht. Also erstmal können die
ja überlegen, möchte ich das machen?
Sie sagen, also was du an dieser Stelle machst, ist ja erstmal,
dass du sagst, pass auf, du kannst ja gerne mit trainieren, aber wenn das in.
Einer Auskunft, die dein Modell erteilt,
eine Rolle spielt, dann möchte ich, also in dem Moment, wo du wirklich das auch davon Nutzen ziehst,
dann möchte ich gerne eine bestimmte Royalty haben.
Das ist ja genau das, was hier Thema war bei dem,
was wir in der letzten Sendung hatten, dass Anthropic Bücher liest und dann
eben dieses Wissen einfach nur aufnimmt, ohne nachher zu referenzieren oder sonstiges.
Und angenommen, ich erfinde jetzt eine neue Programmiersprache oder so,
dann würde man eben sagen, pass auf, du kannst das hier lesen,
aber wenn du jetzt irgendwie wissen, was hier drin ist, in deinen Antworten
verwendest, dann ist das eben Royalty-pflichtig.
Und du könntest ja auch, das kannst du jetzt auch für unterschiedliche Teile
deiner Webseite machen, sagst halt, was weiß ich,
die Startseite zu crawlen ist kostenlos, aber bestimmte Artikel,
da ist eben, da bilde ich mir ein, dass ich neues Wissen in der Menschheit mitgeteilt habe.
Dieses Wissen zu generieren hat mich Arbeit gekostet und für diese Arbeit möchte
ich gerne entlohnt werden und deswegen finde ich es auch völlig in Ordnung wenn
dein Modell das jetzt alles liest und anderen Leuten beibringt und besser macht
als ich aber dann bitte Royalty.
Erstmal geht es ja jetzt hier nur um den technischen Standard.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so,
ob sich das wirklich für ein Modell so abbilden lässt, dass das dann diesen
unglaublichen riesigen Zoo an, was referenziere ich hier überhaupt in meinen
Antworten und was kostet jetzt wieder,
abbilden kann.
Aber zumindest hast du für die Anbieterseite mal einen Standard,
der zumindest die unterschiedlichen Ideen, die es geben könnte,
ein verteiltes Internet und Web zu retten,
einmal strukturiert wiedergebbar macht.
Ja, das nehmen wir jetzt mal zur Kenntnis, dass sie das jetzt so machen wollen.
Ich bin gespannt, ob sich das in irgendeiner Form wirklich durchsetzt.
Ja, also ja, das werden wir sehen, aber die,
es ist zumindest, geht mal jemand mit dem Problem um, das ja nun wirklich auch,
nicht ohne Grund das offene Web gerade beschäftigt.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, das ist natürlich ein Machtkampf an dieser Stelle,
wenn jetzt hier die genannten,
Entities wie Reddit ja, dann sich irgendwie die mit Amazon und OpenAI einigen,
gut, dann haben wir jetzt große amerikanische Medienunternehmen unter sich.
Die Reddit kann halt schnell sehr viel Ärger machen,
weil sie die technischen Möglichkeiten haben und natürlich auch eine ganze Menge
Content raushauen, der ja wiederum von ihren Usern eigentlich bereitgestellt
wird, die mit Sicherheit da nicht beteiligt werden.
Aber ob Kleidere hier in irgendeiner Form die Möglichkeit haben,
so eine Machtposition zu erreichen, da habe ich dann doch meine Zweifel.
Richtig, aber natürlich dadurch,
dass es einen Standard gibt und du dich potenziell, sagen wir mal,
vielleicht so etwas wie einer rechte Verwertungsgesellschaft anschließen könntest,
wird zumindest eine technische Basis dafür geschaffen.
Also könntest du jetzt auch vergleichen mit, was weiß ich, was es damals so
gab und Flatter und was nicht alles.
Wir hatten ja früher den Flatter-Button auf den Logbuch-Netzpolitik-Seiten,
dann gab es Leute, die konnten, da konnte man den Flatter-Button drücken,
dann gab es andere, die hatten Browser-Plugin,
wo einfach automatisch immer, wenn Flatter eingebettet war, hast du halt auch
automatisch geflattert.
Dann war das nicht sogar teilweise in irgendwelchen Podcast-Playern mit drin,
dass du sagen konntest, alles klar, hier, wenn der Podcast, wenn ich den gehört
habe und der hat einen Flatter-Button in den Metadaten, dann flatter ich hier mit und so.
Also das sind ja eben so zaghafte Anfänge von Standards,
die es dann überhaupt ermöglichen, derartige Modelle eventuell in der Breite
anzubieten oder zu bauen.
Nur in diesem Fall eben nicht gegen die Nutzer, sondern gegen die KI als Client.
Und ich glaube.
Dass die Betreiber von solchen LLMs, also wenn das Web aufhört,
Inhalte zu produzieren und dann nichts Neues mehr kommt, dann wäre ja auch Perplexity
oder Google oder Chat-GPT gewissermaßen erledigt.
Das heißt, denen ist schon klar, dass sie für neue Inhalte, genuin neue Inhalte,
was weiß ich, Nachrichten,
neue Jugendwörter, neue Memes, dass sie dafür in irgendeiner Weise,
dass das sie Geld kosten wird.
Weil wenn sie dauerhaft dafür nichts zahlen und gleichzeitig aber das Interface
dazu werden wollen, dann wird es diese Inhalte nicht mehr geben.
Ja, naja, aber es kann natürlich auch genauso gut dazu führen,
dass jetzt irgendwie alle auf die Idee kommen, auf ihre Inhalte ein Preisschild
drauf zu machen und ob das dann in langer Sicht dem Web so gut tut,
da habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
Ich meine auch bei diesem Web 3, diesem Krypto-Asset-Wahnsinns-Idee von wir
machen jetzt hier irgendwie alles mit Blockchain und Bitcoin und so weiter,
gab es ja auch diese Idee, dass irgendwie so alles wird jetzt irgendwie monetarisiert,
überall klebt jetzt ein Preis drauf und das ist natürlich nichts,
was jetzt sagen wir mal dem Web an sich sehr gut tut an der Stelle.
Also ja, ich sehe den Ansatz.
Ich habe so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, dass das außer bei großen Playern,
die sich in gewisser Hinsicht auf sowas dann einigen müssen,
weil sie eben gegenüber klare Machtpositionen haben, die sie ausspielen können,
dass die sich dann darauf einigen können, dass das jetzt ein generelles Ding
wird, was sich im Web groß durchsetzt. Da habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
Aber Zweifel heißt nicht, dass hier nicht auch irgendwas bei rauskommen kann.
Ich wollte die bloß mal kurz vermeldet haben, die Zweifel.
Ohne Frage. Also das ist schon so richtig.
So, dann gab es eine Veranstaltung mit dem wohlklingenden Namen Big Bang KI Festival,
wo man sich auch fragt, warum das nicht Big Bang AI oder Urknall KI Festival
hieß, aber es hieß halt Big Bang KI Festival.
Warst du da?
Nee, ich habe nur mit Erstaunen gelesen, was die Gematik-Geschäftsführerin Brenja
Adje da gesagt hat. Ich hoffe, ich habe den Namen richtig ausgesprochen. Ich lese ihn da nur.
Sie hat dort bekannt gegeben, ja, also rund 80 Prozent der Praxen könnten jetzt
auf die elektronische Patientenakte zugreifen.
Dafür hätten sie hunderte Interviews und 600 Tickets lösen müssen.
Interessante Statistik und die elektronische Medikationsliste also wer hat welche
in deiner EPA steht, was du für Medikamente nimmst, die hätte jetzt erste Leben gerettet,
das ist ja auch immer so also das war ja eine der,
der Visionen von Karl Lauterbach Beleg gab es da jetzt nicht,
aber nehmen wir jetzt mal zur Kenntnis, dass wahrscheinlich inzwischen irgendeine
Ärztin schon mal in der Medikationsliste eine wertvolle Information hatte.
Was ich.
Lustig finde, also wirklich unterhaltsam finde, ist, dass sie sagt,
ja, es gibt ja einerseits Beschwerden wegen des Datenschutzes und andererseits,
wegen geringer Nutzerzahlen.
Wo ich mich frage, wo ist denn da der Gegensatz? Ich meine, der Grund hieß ja,
dass das Ding halt einfach ...
Wir erinnern uns, die Daten liegen da größtenteils ungeschützt,
unverschlüsselt, frei zugreifbar drin.
Die haben irgendwie drei Anläufe
versucht, mit irgendwelchen Nicht-Geheimnissen den Zugang zu sichern.
Aber sie hat da eine komplett andere Perspektive drauf.
Sie sagt, der Vorteil wäre, dass es die EPA noch nicht so lange gibt und sie
sei eben state of the art und auch schon KI-ready.
Und das würde bei anderen Ländern zu Neid führen.
So, da frage ich mich, also The State of the Art. Die sind alle nur neidisch.
Geil.
Die sind alle nur neidisch.
So, und Ja,
das muss ich mir merken, wenn das nächste Mal sich jemand über unser Bahnnetz
oder unser Mobilfunknetz beschwert.
Ihr seid doch alle nur neidisch.
Und jetzt frage ich, was ich halt super geil finde, ist, also was ist denn,
was zeichnet denn KI-Readyness aus?
Also wenn du sagst, etwas ist KI-Ready, das heißt, also wie würde ich jetzt
eine große Daten, was zeichnet eine große Datensammlung aus, dass sie KI-Ready ist?
Erstmal, sie ist unverschlüsselt Und sie ist ein großer Datensatz an zentraler Stelle.
Das sind ja die beiden, also das ist KI-Readiness, insofern hat sie ja recht.
Aber ich meine, das Geile wäre halt gewesen, das Ding genau nicht KI-ready zu bauen.
Also das Designziel von besonders schützenswerten Daten zentral gespeichert
wäre, es ist nicht unmittelbar als Trainingsmaterial für die KI nutzbar.
Das wäre die Idee gewesen. Und das nennt sie jetzt, das hat auch der Lauterbach
gesagt, das wäre die Gnade der späten Geburt.
Und da frage ich, also das ist halt so absurd.
Da haben wir sie wieder.
Also das ist, also die Gnade der späten Geburt, dafür müsste das Ding ja irgendeine
Technologie haben, irgendetwas, was man vor 30 Jahren nicht gehabt hätte.
Und das haben sie ja nicht.
Das ist ja von Standards, Technologien, Sicherheit, sonst was,
das ist alles noch nicht mal ordentlich zugriffsgeschützt.
Und davon irgendwie Gnade der späten Geburt oder sowas zu reden,
weil wir es so spät gemacht haben. Die anderen sind nicht KI-ready.
Die haben die Daten nämlich sicher verschlüsselt.
Also wirklich, das ist schon sehr weit weg.
Ja, da bricht sich die Ahnungslosigkeit wieder Bahn. Das ist schon wirklich erstaunlich.
KI-ready. Leute, kommt doch mal von eurem Hype-Ross runter. Es ist doch einfach,
also kann man jetzt keinen klaren Satz mehr aussprechen, ohne irgendwie immer
gleich über KI zu schwadronieren?
Ich meine, vor fünf Jahren konntest du nichts ohne Blockchain sagen,
jetzt muss überall KI drin sein.
Das meine ich gerade in der späten Geburt, sie können ja keine.
Ja, also man kann auch eine technische Diskussion führen,
ohne die ganze Zeit in Buzzwords zu sprechen und mittelfristig,
also ich verstehe, dass bestimmte Leute nur auf sowas reagieren und denken,
alles was jetzt nicht gerade Buzzword compliant ist,
das ist dann irgendwie nichts wert, aber so in the long run zählt einfach nur
Kompetenz und da muss man nicht sowas sagen, ich meine, das ist einfach Quark.
Ich bin ja pro dieser Sicht mit, es ist schon okay, wenn man jetzt medizinische Daten hat,
dass man die auch anonym irgendwie für Forschung nutzen können soll.
Mag nicht jeder so sehen, ich sehe das so und das ist ja auch alles in Ordnung,
aber das ist ja alles überhaupt gar keine Entschuldigung dafür,
dass das Ganze so technisch so blöd ist.
Der KI-Ready ist auf jeden Fall finde ich einen geilen KI-Ready.
Bist du KI-Ready eigentlich? Sag mal, Linus.
Ich bin KI-Ready, ja. Ich habe auch hier alle meine Daten auf einem Haufen unverschesselt liegen.
Schöner Begriff. Also wirklich, Mann, Mann, Mann.
Ich finde dieses Wort KI-Ready so schön?
Ja, weil es wirklich halt, natürlich kannst du da die ganzen Leute, boah, Leute,
die elektronische Patientenakte ist KI-Ready und was, aber das KI halt,
die Idee ist halt massenhaft unstrukturierte Daten irgendwie sinnvoll auszuwerten,
dann ist halt schon die Frage, wie irgendetwas nicht KI-Ready wäre.
Ja, ich würde mir mehr Kultur wünschen, um ehrlich zu sein.
Natürlich, das ist ja auch das, das ist ja tatsächlich auch das Problem von
diesem Ding, was ja auch viele Leute sagen, ist ja super, dass das KI-ready
ist, aber am Ende ist es halt ein Haufen PDFs, den Leute unstrukturiert irgendwie aufeinander werfen.
Ja, ist KI-ready, ist aber auch nur KI-ready, wäre schöner gewesen,
wenn es irgendwie eine halbwegs strukturierte Datenhaltung da gäbe.
Währenddessen, es gibt, es wurden,
70 Millionen E-Paths angelegt, Ähm Sehr Wenige haben Widersprochen Ähm.
Aber von den 70 Millionen E-Pass,
auf die können überhaupt nur 3,3 Millionen Versicherte zugreifen,
weil sich nur 3,3 Millionen die Gesundheits-ID haben ausstellen lassen,
die für den Login in diese Telematik-Infrastruktur zum Beispiel E-Pass notwendig wären.
Das heißt irgendwie, also etwas über 70 Millionen,
66,7 Millionen E-Pass hat noch nie eine Patientin darauf zugegriffen und außerdem,
und dann sagen sie, wird außerdem,
Hunderttausende haben sich schon in ihre Akte eingeloggt.
Oder Hunderttausende loggen sich da regelmäßig ein also 70 Millionen so Dinger
3,3 Millionen können sich überhaupt einloggen, Hunderttausende tun es und als Begründung,
es fehlt den Menschen an Wissen oder Vertrauen in diese digitale Anwendung ja ach Ja, ach!
Also natürlich, wenn das Ding halt irgendwie... Naja, schade.
Aber es ist KI-Ready und Gnade der späten Geburt, das finde ich wirklich...
Also den Begriff sollte man für sowas sowieso nicht verwenden.
KI-Ready.
Das war ja ursprünglich... Ich muss mir mal kurz überlegen, wer hat den Spruch
ursprünglich gebracht? Das war...
Welchen Spruch?
Gnade der späten Geburt ist ja eigentlich ein Begriff, der im Kontext der Auseinandersetzung
mit der Nazizeit gefallen ist.
Gnade der späten Geburt ist ein von dem deutschen Bundeskanzler Helmut Kohl
in den Jahren 1983, 1984 geprägter Ausspruch, der zum Ausdruck bringen sollte,
dass die Deutschen, die nach 1930 geboren wurden,
im Nationalsozialismus nicht schuldig werden konnten.
Sie waren so spät geboren worden, dass sie sich nicht selbst und bewusst für
oder gegen den Nationalsozialismus entscheiden mussten.
Gelungen. Ursprünglich wurde der Begriff vom Journalisten Günther Gauss verwendet.
So, jetzt müssen wir gucken, was die Wikipedia, von der ich jetzt zitiert habe,
als Lizenz, ah ne, das wäre ja nur KI.
Also das durften wir jetzt noch.
Ja, sehr gelungen, sehr gelungener Vergleich.
Also wirklich echt, Leute.
Komm.
So viel Gnade habt ihr gar nicht erfahren, wenn ihr immer noch so doof da herredet.
Gnade, Gnade, Gnade. Alright. Die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte ist jetzt
die Freiheit Zehnjähriges.
Oha.
Finde ich auch interessant. Oder ja, kann man vor allem meinen,
ist ein Blick auf mein Alter wahrscheinlich.
Und ich glaube, wir feiern das jetzt auch irgendwann die Tage hier in Berlin dann. Und haben zudem,
zudem mal eine Seite zusammengestellt mit ihren zehn größten Erfolgen.
Die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte hat 70 von der GFF koordinierte Verfahren geführt,
die bis heute auch entschieden wurden.
In drei von vier Fällen ungefähr erzielen sie einen Erfolg.
Insgesamt über 100 Verfahren angestrengt, darunter 45 Verfassungsbeschwerden.
Und auf dieser Seite stellen Sie jetzt Ihre Top Ten Erfolge vor.
Ich will die jetzt nicht alle im Detail behandeln, den größeren Teil davon haben
wir sowieso in der Sendung behandelt.
Aber ich fand das mal ganz gut als Überblick, was in den letzten zehn Jahren
in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland Grundrechtsfragen waren.
Das ist nämlich eigentlich das interessante Bild.
2020 BND-Gesetz, Grundrechte gelten auch im Ausland. Da ging es um das BND-Gesetz.
Investigativjournalistinnen hatten dann mit der GFF eine Verfassungsbeschwerde
gegen diese Novelle und dann wurde gesagt, alles klar,
diese Überwachungspraxis ist verfassungswidrig, weil sie Fernmeldegeheimnis
und Pressefreiheit verletzt, eben potenziell auch von deutschen Grundrechtsträgerinnen im Ausland.
Also BND-Überwachung ist Thema eins. Erfolg zwei, menschenwürdiges Leben auch
in Sammelunterkünften.
Da ging es um gekürzte Sozialleistungen für Schutzsuchende, die eben unter dem
menschenwürdigen Existenzminimum lagen.
Also Schutzsuchende.
Bayerischer, Erfolg Nummer drei, Bundesverfassungsgericht setzt bayerischem
Verfassungsschutz Grenzen, also wieder Überwachung.
Erfolg 4. Versammlungsfreiheit gilt auch für Protestcamps.
Da haben sie Protestcamps als nicht grundrechtlich geschützte Versammlungen
wahrgenommen und die GFF hat dann vor dem Bundesverwaltungsgericht geklärt,
dass eben die Übernachtungsflächen im Klimacamp Garzweiler von der Versammlungsfreiheit geschützt waren.
Also erstens Versammlungsrecht, zweitens dann noch friedlich und Thema hier
spezifisch Klimawandel.
Erfolg 5. Hessen-Data. Polizei verletzt mit Data Mining Grundrechte.
Also hier KI-Auswertung von Überwachungsdaten oder von Vielzahl an Daten eben
auch Unbeteiligte, also wieder ein Massenüberwachungsthema.
Erfolg 6, Equal Pay, gleicher Lohn, ist keine Verhandlungssache.
Da ging es also um die Benachteiligung von Mitarbeiterinnen,
in diesem speziellen Fall in einem sächsischen Metallbauunternehmen,
die deutlich weniger Lohn als
ihr männlicher Kollege in diesem Fall bei gleicher Qualifikation hatten.
Argument des Unternehmens, der Kollege hat halt besser verhandelt.
Da können wir noch nichts für.
Er folgt sieben öffentliche Kritik an der Polizei.
Da hat jemand persönliche Erfahrungen mit der Polizei geteilt und rassistische Strukturen bemängelt.
Und das war Baha Aslan, die an der Polizeihochschule NRW lehrte.
Und dann hat die Hochschule gesagt,
wenn du rassistische Strukturen bei der Polizei kritisierst,
dann bist du ungeeignet an der Polizeifachhochschule weiterhin als Dozentin
für interkulturelle Kompetenz zu arbeiten. Also verloren.
Sie beweisen sich sozusagen selber. Sehr schön.
Dann Erfolg 8, Bezahlkarte, muss individuelle Lebensumstände berücksichtigen,
also dieses gesamte Modell,
dass in den Sozialleistungen für Geflüchtete, dass sie kein Bargeld zur freien
Verfügung kriegen, sondern diese Bezahlkarte, die ja dann eben nur für bestimmte Dinge,
Ausgaben ermöglicht und quasi eine Kontrolle derer Finanzströme.
Erfolg 9, Schmerzgriffe bei friedlichem Protest, ja auch so eine klassische Thematik,
wenn Menschen eine Sitzblockade machen.
Welche Maßnahmen darf die Polizei anwenden, um diese Sitzblockade aufzulösen?
Und dazu gehört natürlich, die Polizei darf die Leute wegtragen.
Was die Polizei aber ganz gerne mal macht, ist, dass sie Kampfsportgriffe anwenden,
die den Leuten sehr starke Schmerzen zufügen.
Beispielsweise die Hand so nach unten wegknicken und dich dann an der Hand,
an der verdrehten Hand beim Aufstehen begleiten.
Weil du natürlich automatisch aufstehst, weil die Alternative ist,
die brechen dir die Hand ab.
Und das wurde dann eben auch im März 2025 für rechtswidrig abgeurteilt.
Und Erfolg Nummer 10, willkürliche Sperren bei Facebook gefährden die Kunstfreiheit.
Also doch eine Reihe, also wir haben, wenn ich das jetzt nochmal durchgehe,
hast du eine Statistik jetzt mitgeführt?
Also Massenüberwachung 1, Geflüchtetenbehandlung
1, Verfassungsschutz ist wieder, Massenüberwachung 2.
Versammlungsfreiheit für Protestcamps ist, sagen wir mal, Themenbereich Grundrechte bei Protesten.
Hessendata, dritte zur Überwachung, Equal Pay, würde ich sagen vierter Themenbereich,
Geschlechtergerechtlichkeit.
Öffentliche Kritik an der Polizei, würde ich sagen Protestrechte,
so zwei für Protestrechte.
Bezahlkarte, wieder Geflüchtete, also auch zweimal Geflüchtete.
Schmerzgriffe bei Protest, dritter für Protest.
Und ja, Facebook, willkürliche Sperren wäre dann so Zensur.
Also Überwachung, Zensur, Protestrechte und Umgang mit Geflüchteten sind die
Themen, mit denen sich die,
Bundesrepublik Deutschland in den letzten zehn Jahren, in den bedeutendsten
Fällen, das ist jetzt auch eine subjektive Auswahl, aber die Auswahl der GFF
ist natürlich auch irgendwie nach Impact, würde ich jetzt mal sagen.
Wenn Sie sagen, das sind die wichtigsten Erfolge für die Gesellschaft,
dann heißt das eben natürlich auch, dass das die einflussreichsten Grundrechtsverletzungen
waren, die durch die GFF korrigiert wurden.
Deswegen fand ich das so als Bestandsaufnahme durchaus interessant.
Ja, ich würde auch sagen, für jeden was dabei. Oder anders formuliert,
das betrifft euch auch alle irgendwie irgendwann auf irgendeine Art und Weise.
Also oft hat man ja so Fälle, wo man sich denkt, naja, egal, betrifft mich ja nicht.
Aber es betrifft einen schon und vor allem kann es einen potenziell eben in
der Zukunft oder auch indirekt betreffen weil wenn Protest,
nicht mehr möglich ist dann hat das natürlich auch langfristige Auswirkungen
auf politische Bereiche, wo
vielleicht jetzt nicht in dem konkreten Fall gerade für protestiert wurde,
morgen könnte es eben auch dann dein Interesse sein Insofern muss ich sagen,
fand ich die ganze Initiative, diese Organisation überhaupt erstmal zu gründen,
sehr lobenswert und ich bin ehrlich gesagt ziemlich beeindruckt mit wie viel Werbe,
Intensität und letztlich eben auch Erfolg, das über die Zeit betrieben wurde.
Dass es auch, sagen wir mal, so ein Ort ist für Rechtsleute,
für Juristen mal jenseits des normalen Bestrafens und Verteidigens sich zu engagieren,
sich einfach mal konkret für Grundrechte einzusetzen und insofern Chapeau,
also das war wirklich solide Arbeit und verdient auch die Unterstützung.
Also toll, dass es das gibt. Ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher.
Ich glaube, wir hatten Ulf damals, kurz nach der Gründung, auch im Podcast,
auch diese Idee der strategischen Litigation, das macht die GFF ja. sie schaut sich,
einerseits eben bei Hessen Data und sowas, wo es dann eben um Gesetze geht,
die, oder bei dem BND-Gesetz, wo sie sagen, okay, das ist hier, das kann so nicht sein.
Damit du aber dann eine Verfassungsbeschwerde machen kannst,
brauchst du ja Betroffene und das ist ja das, was die GFF so ein bisschen,
ja, wie nennt man das denn?
Facilitated. ermöglicht, dass sie sagen, wir, das hier setzt.
Also offensichtlich ist diese gesetzliche Regelung geeignet,
die Rechte von Journalistinnen, die im Ausland tätig sind, zu verletzen,
das können wir so nicht stehen lassen, jetzt suchen wir uns geeignete Klägerinnen,
die diesen Punkt vorbringen können, den wir als Juristinnen hier sehen,
wir brauchen eben eine Betroffene, damit wir in die,
Verfassungsbeschwerde gehen können und dann ziehen wir das durch.
Und ich hätte, es ist ja auf eine Weise auch spannend, wie viel Arbeit so ein
Staat, so eine Organisation dann macht.
Also ja.
Ja, ich gucke gerade, also wir hatten Ulf einige Male da,
auch schon vor der GFF-Gründung, bin mir gerade nicht so sicher,
ob wir eigentlich die GFS selbst jemals so im Zentrum der Debatte hatten,
aber da er im Januar 2016 da war,
haben wir das quasi über Bande thematisiert.
Ja, ja, dann wird er das Bande. Ja, also GFF, herzlichen Glückwunsch viele Jahre weiter.
Und ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie groß dieser Laden inzwischen ist.
Es sind auf jeden Fall viele Juristinnen und...
Die haben auf jeden Fall ein ziemlich großes Büro. Also ich müsste jetzt mal
gucken, was da... Haben die das hier auf der Transparenz?
Ach nee, Transparenz ist ein Themenbereich, nicht.
Merge. sieben gute Gründe, die GFF zu unterstützen.
Also es ist wirklich eine spannende...
Auf der Team-Seite muss man auf jeden Fall schon ganz schön scrollen,
bis man alle Bilder mal gesehen hat.
Ah, du hast die Team-Seite gefunden? Ich hab sie gefunden, ja.
Das ist wahrscheinlich über uns Team.
Genau. Ich hab's jetzt nicht durchgezählt, aber das sind mal so locker 20, 30 Leute.
Ja. Dann Happy Birthday.
Das sind auch noch mal mehr. Ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch und noch viele weitere Erfolge der GFF.
Achso, jetzt sehe ich hier gerade.
Dass die GFF ja mit auch an der Strafanzeige gegen Finn Fischer beteiligt war
und damals ja zum Beispiel auch die Finn Fischer Analyse,
die Thorsten und ich gemacht haben mit den Analyse-Tools,
dass das quasi auch von der GFF ausging und wir das für die GFF gemacht haben.
Und dass das ja auch zur Folge hatte, dass dieser Export von Finzbay an die türkische Regierung,
wo Finzbay dann offensichtlich gegen die politische Opposition eingesetzt wurde
und dass dieser Export unter Umgehung von Exportkontrollen stattgefunden hatte, Was dazu führte,
dass diese Firma an 13 oder so durchsucht wurde und das Vermögen eingefroren
wurde und die Firma danach erledigt war, das haben die noch nicht mal als einen
ihrer größten Erfolge auf der Liste.
Da verbirgt sich ja nur eine ganze Menge weitere Dinge hinter, was sie so getan haben.
Ja, cool. Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Letztes Thema.
Und dann, machen wir noch kurz zum letzten Mal Chat-Kontrolle.
Es gibt jetzt wieder einen Vorstoß,
dass sich die Staaten einigen wollen, irgendwie die Chat-Kontrolle,
also die KI-Scanner auf den Geräten anzusehen.
Europaweit zu vereinbaren und da gibt es jetzt mal wieder und das ist ja so schmerzhaft.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele offene Briefe kompetenter Leute es inzwischen
gegen die Chatkontrolle gibt.
In diesem Fall 470 Wissenschaftlerinnen aus 34 Ländern.
Die sich gegen diesen erneuten Vorschlag zur Chatkontrolle wenden,
der von der dänischen Ratspräsidentschaft in den Rat eingebracht wurde.
Und haben wir verlinkt, nochmal darauf hinweisen, sagen, es ist schlichtweg unmöglich,
bekannte und neue Darstellung des sexuellen Mitbrauchs von Kindern für hunderte
Millionen Nutzerinnen und Nutzer mit einer akzeptablen Genauigkeit zu erkennen,
unabhängig von der eingesetzten Filtertechnik.
Darüber hinaus untergräbt eine Detektion direkt auf dem Gerät,
unabhängig von ihrer technischen Umsetzung, von Natur aus den Schutz,
den Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung eigentlich gewährleisten soll.
Und das sind ja fundamentale Wahrheiten,
auf die jetzt hier nochmal 470 Wissenschaftlerinnen hinweisen müssen.
Ein ganzes Parlament, dem das bei jeder Gelegenheit und eine ganze Kommission
und wer da alles sitzt und ein ganzer Rat, dem das bei jeder Gelegenheit nochmal erklärt wird.
Ähnlich wie seine Vorgänger macht auch dieser Vorschlag, schafft beispiellose
Möglichkeiten für Überwachung, Kontrolle und Zensur, inhärentes Risiko für Missbrauch.
Das heute erreichte Sicherheits- und Datenschutzniveau in der digitalen Kommunikation
und IT-System ist das Ergebnis jahrzehntelanger gemeinsamer Anstrengungen von
Forschung, Industrie und Politik.
Dieser Vorschlag wird diese Sicherheits- und Datenschutzmaßnahmen,
die für die gesamte digitale Gesellschaft Schutz bieten, vollständig untergraben.
Aber, und auch die Unsinnigkeit des gesamten Ansatzes, es ist zum Verrücktwerden,
wie hier auch wieder so eine komplette Beratungsresistenz gegenüber der,
ja,
der ja nun mal,
was soll das? So, Ende der Sendung.
Okay.
Ja, was soll man sonst noch sagen? Es ist okay, wir sagen da jetzt auch nichts
mehr zu, es ist schon alles gesagt, aber wir werden weiterhin darauf hinweisen,
dass immer mehr Leute nochmal was dazu sagen, obwohl schon alle was dazu gesagt haben.
Ja, also das ist, ich will auch gar nicht, also nochmal, nicht,
da sagt nur jemand was, obwohl es schon von allen gesagt wurde.
Das ist ja das Problem, dass du denen das immer wieder sagen musst und sie es
auch immer und immer wieder ignorieren werden. Es ist ja leider nicht so,
dass da was Neues drinsteht.
Es ist nur leider immer nochmal notwendig, das immer und immer wieder neu zu erklären.
Und da kann man jeder unterzeichnenden Wissenschaftlerin dankbar sein,
dass sie das noch macht, weil gerade Wissenschaftler haben ja so eine Tendenz,
idealerweise was Neues rausfinden zu wollen.
Und wenn sie was einmal gesagt haben, das nächste Neue rausfinden zu wollen,
weißt du? So einem Wissenschaftler zu sagen, könntest du noch mal,
das mit den Naturgesetzen noch mal erklären? Das ist halt,
auf Dauer belastend.
Ist das wirklich so mit diesem könnten wir nicht einfach Gravitation abschalten?
Können wir nicht einfach sagen, der Apfel fällt nach oben und nach unten?
Genau.
Das kann ja nicht, wieso jetzt? Wieso sollten wir nicht einfach mal schneller,
mit dem Verbrennermotor kann man doch bestimmt auch schneller als Lichtgeschwindigkeit
sein, wenn man das jetzt mal technologieoffen macht?
Ja, können wir das nicht nur mit der Alchemie nochmal probieren,
vielleicht können wir ja doch Gold machen.
Ja.
Also gerade für Wissenschaftler ist das belastend.
Die wollen neue Sachen sagen.
Nicht nur für Wissenschaftler. So.
Ja, für mich.
Wir machen jetzt Schluss.
Wir machen Schluss. Und regen uns nächste Woche auf.
Genau.
Nächste Woche regen wir uns über was anderes auf. Ist doch auch schön.
Genau, solange machen wir KI-Ready. Oder? Also ich bin, ich fühle mich,
ich spüre es in mir. Ich bin auch KI-Ready.
Hier hinten eine kleine Dehnung.
So eine kleine Datendehnung.
Okay, also ihr wisst, schön üben bis nächste Woche, auch dass ihr auch alle KI-Ready seid. Für uns.
Ja, und vom Training müsst ihr die Daten dehnen.
Tschüss Leute, bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.